[Applaudissements]
elles sont chouettes mes baskets
j'adore mes baskets pourtant il suffit
d'une critique et moi je me retrouve à
côté de mes pompes
immédiatement je peux des chaussées et
je peux même atterrir dans les godasses
de l'autre et là autant vous dire c'est
pas ma pointure c'est pas ma couleur et
c'est pas mon style
j'adore j'adopte son point de vue et
vous face à une critique ou sont et
comment
réfléchissez un peu à la maison au
boulot
une critique quand vous sentez vous face
à une critique en faire un petit sondage
vérifier si comme moi quand vous recevez
une critique
vous vous sentez un petit peu coupé dans
vos élans levez la main si vous êtes
comme moi je me sens moins seul lever la
main si vous sentez comme un petit
malaise face à une critique
voilà alors moi face à une critique
j'ai un truc pour me rendre la vie plus
belle et ce soir je suis venu vous
présenter et vous partager un petit
processus de communication non violente
parce que sa femme permet de retrouver
mes baskets et la paix qui va avec
pour vous expliquer comment ça marche
je vais vous raconter comment j'ai
cheminé avec une critique que j'ai
reçues au sujet de mon spectacle
donc c'était il ya un an deux ans
peut-être enfin deux en deux ans le
début de mon spectacle deuxième
représentation
j'invite juil et moi je suis hyper
confiante je suis sûr que ça va lui
plaire parce qu'on me dit que mon
spectacle il va pouvoir être remboursés
par la sécurité sociale
ça fait un peu l'effet d'un
antidépresseur voyez puis julie beau jeu
son avis qui compte pour moi quand même
hein je travaille souvent avec elle
j'adore ce qu'elle fait cette fille je
me raconte même qu'à cette occasion on
pourrait devenir copines toutes les deux
sauf qu'à la sortie et du war à mayol
qu'est ce qui t'a pris à dubaï
n'importe quoi en faire ça
alors sur le coup là j'ai pas plu du
tout l'écouté et puis j'étais comme
sidéré j'étais devenu l'ombre de
moi-même j'étais hors de moi j'avais des
chaussées canton des choses comme ça
immédiatement on peut adopter une vision
binaire du monde
on joue à un petit jeu le jeu de qui a
tort qui a raison
alors tout de suite j'ai dit non non un
homme alors étudié complètement folle a
dit n'importe quoi
puis allez sûrement jalouse donc je
réfléchis un petit peu puis le lendemain
eh ben j'ai atterri dans ses baskets
voyez non j'ai adopté son point de vue
là c'est sûr un c'est sûr que là si
c'est nul comme ça moi je peux je peux
arrêter alors on peut aussi les comme ça
d'un jour à l'autre mais aussi d'une
seconde alors voyez un bel arrêt zoula
et la raison et non voilà tort et c'est
comme ça que nous perdons pied
c'est ce qui m'est arrivé
c'était le début de la tournée j'avais
tellement honte que je vous ai plus
parlé de mon spectacle à personne
pendant des semaines
et puis j'ai préféré éviter julie et ses
amis parce que l'avait j'avais juste
envie de lui dire ses quatre vérités à
julie souvenons donc à ce stade à
vouloir dire à l'autre ses quatre
vérités
c'est comme ça que nous déclenchons des
guerres là moi c'était pas ma préférence
donc là c'était vraiment j'étais
vraiment contente d'avoir découvert le
processus de communication non violente
avec marshall rosenberg ce processus
c c'est un art de vivre avec soi avec
les autres
dans la bienveillance l'art du bien
vivre ensemble et quand on pratique ce
petit processus on sait que vivre à côté
de ses pompes à cause d'une critique et
passait pas une fatalité
alors comment j'ai fait moi le jour j'ai
décidé de retrouver un petit peu mes
baskets
j'ai pris mon carnet sur l'étagère dans
la cuisine je me suis assise je me suis
fait mon petit café et là j'ai noté tous
mes jugements pourrez vous auriez vu ça
vous auriez dit là isabelle envoie du
lourd sur julie et oui c'est ça
à ce stade en ruminant en boucle contre
l'autre on s'en fera fabrique des images
d'ennemis alors le processus de
communication non violente mais qu'est
ce que c'est ces 5 4 étapes première
étape
l'observation nous des mélanges on aux
observations de nos jugements
nous observons objectivement ce que nous
voyons ce que nous entendons deuxième
étape les sentiments alors là nous
accueillons nos ressentis nos émotions
et nos états d'âme et ce qui est
intéressant c'est de les voir un petit
peu comme des clignotants sur un tableau
de bord parce que ça ça donne des clés
pour décoder nos frustrations troisième
étape le besoin je me relie à mes
aspirations profondes à mes valeurs à
mes rêves 4e étape
c'est comme ça que je vais pouvoir
passer à l'action en conscience et je
vais faire une demande à l'autre à moi à
quelqu'un d'autre
alors comment ça se pratique ce donne un
exemple avec julie parce que là il y
avait matière je pouvais traduire mes
jugements sur elle et sur moi en
aspiration profonde je la juge la gratte
là julie ça fait un jugement donc
j'observe
première étape qu'est ce que j'entends
j'entends ça sert à rien de faire sa ba
oui mais quand j'entends ça moi je me
sens dépité parce que finalement j'ai
besoin de reconnaissance là j'ai besoin
de reconnaissance pour tous les efforts
que ça m'a demandé de tarifs pour
arriver jusque là j'ai besoin de
reconnaissance pour tous les et les
soutiens qui m'ont encouragé à aller
jusque là
et puis et puis autant vous dire que les
enfants ils ont quand même accepté de
partager leur chambre pour qu'on puisse
souvent une partie de la maison pour
financer le projet donc j'avais aussi
besoin de reconnaissance pour mes
enfants
j'étais plein de gratitude de découvrir
ça donc je me suis fait une demande je
me suis dit mais valve et gilles heures
à tes enfants merci de tout le ton coeur
et voilà avec ce processus 11e' quatre
étapes c'est simple on peut cheminer au
fil des jours
sauf que dans la vraie vie huras a été
rude parce que ça m'a pris du temps ça
m'a pris presque tout un été de faire ça
alors évidemment j'ai reçus de
l'empathie de mon entourage il comptait
beaucoup pour moi à ce moment là mais
j'ai aussi bien aimé me souvenir de ce
que m'avait dit thomas dans ce bourg lui
un saint mais formateur à la
communication non violente
il m'avait dit isabelle être heureux
c'est pas nécessairement confortable
c'est aussi le titre d'un de ses livres
mais ça franchement ça m'a donné du
courage pour me reprendre mon carnet il
me remettre ma tâche de pratiquer ce
processus je vous donne à notre exemple
à ce stade là jugé nulles julie mais oui
mais je la juge eut mais qu'est ce que
j'observe la première étape
j'observe quoi je suis en train de la
fuir alors que j'espérais qu'on allait
devenir copier je me sens tellement déçu
parce que moi j'aimerais j'ai besoin de
complicité avec elle alors j'ai fait une
demande à une copine lui d'y aller
organise un petit dîner avec julie on va
refaire la connexion en simple voilà
avec ce processus bienveillance avec moi
c'est le premier pas vers la paix
bienveillance avec l'autre je retrouve
doucement de la paix dans mes baskets de
la tranquillité à l'intérieur et donc à
ce stade on peut aussi accueillir
l'autre avec ses sentiments et ses
besoins
sauf que moi dans mon histoire
julie et n'a jamais pu venir au dîner
j'ai pas pu lui parler et en même temps
l'avantagé avec ce processus c'est que
les gens soient là ou pas on peut se
relier de choeur à coeur
j'ai fait ça avec elle elle dit ça sert
à rien de faire ça ouais c'est sûrement
qu'elle se sent déçu parce qu'elle n'y
trouve pas ce qu'elle espérait est pas
elle a le droit d'avoir des rêves rêver
c'est un besoin universel
moi aussi j'ai le même et puis un autre
exemple elle n'avait dit qu'elle avait
besoin de cohérence sur trois points
mais finalement j'ai été assez touché
d'entendre ça parce que j'avais la même
aspiration alors je suis passé à
l'action je me suis allé il avait le cul
relis ton texte tu vérifies la cohérence
du texte avec des intentions de départ
et puis tu en profite pour rajouter des
sources au passage j'ai même réaliser
finalement que si elle n'était pas venu
c'est sûrement parce qu'elles étaient
débordés et puis je me suis souvenu que
les gens ne mesurent souvent pas
l'impact que leurs mots peuvent savoir
sur nous comme un stimulus sur nos
blessures
voilà bienveillance avec moi
bienveillance avec l'autre avec ce
processus on retrouve la paix dans ses
baskets et c'est à partir de cet endroit
là qu'on peut voir la critique comme un
cadeau le cadeau de ce qui est vivant
chez l'autre le cadeau de ce qui est
important pour lui juste un cadeau mal
emballé alors moi je suis contente
d'avoir connu tout ça parce que j'y
retrouvais la paix dans mes baskets et
j'ai recontacté mon élan de vie ça ça
m'a permis de jouer je crois que 45
dates jusqu'à aujourd'hui est de cumuler
6000 spectateurs au total
j'ai eu plein de soutien et je suis tout
excité à l'idée d'écrire mon deuxième
spectacle
alors je vous dis pas que j'ai plus peur
de la critique mais je me sens un tout
petit peu plus équipés mais toujours un
peu vulnérable alors au final
moi je crois que personne ne nous
demande d'être ailleurs que dans nos
baskets c'est pas facile de traverser
les épreuves de la vie mais c'est
possible c'est possible de le faire le
coeur ouvert si on sait accueillir la
vie qui nous traversent dans la
bienveillance
c'est possible si comme moi on a appris
à le faire alors la bonne nouvelle c'est
que vivre la paix dans ses baskets et
ben ça s'apprend c'est comme le vélo et
il n'y a pas d'âge pour commencer
merci
[Applaudissements]